[موسيقى]
العلاقات الامريكيه السعوديه وفي ليبيا
الكارثه ولم تنتهي واشنطن تستدعي
[موسيقى]
الامور تجري عكس عقارب الساعه في اوكرانيا
نفذ صبرها ليعلن البيت الابيض استدعاء
الرئيس الاوكراني
على وجه سرعه وفي مده نقصها اسبوع تعال يا
واد بسرعه مات يلا وذلك بحسب ما صرح به
مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي الذي اضاف
انه ياتي بالتاكيد في وقت الحرج حيث تسعى
روسيا بشده للحصول على المساعده من دول
مثل كوريا الشماليه في حرب الوحشيه مع
اوكرانيا بينما تسعى القوات الاوكرانيه
الى مواصله احراز تقدم في هجومها المضاد
وفق تعبيره وكانت شبكه سي ان ان قد قالت
تنازل الاسكي سيزور ايضا الكونجرس خلال
الرحله فما الذي يخطط له ابناء العم سام
من استدعاء زلميسكي ليجيب سالف
تقوم دائما باعداد مساعدات عسكريه جديده
لاوكرانيا مبينا ان واشنطن تخطط لتسليم
المزيد من الاسلحه الجديده والنوعيه
الاسبوع المقبل والتي ستشكل فارقا في سير
المعارك كثره الاسلحه النوعيه التي تصل
الى الاراضي الاوكرانيه لتلقى علاجا نافع
في صيدليه بوتين فلكل داء دواء وها هو
الزعيم الكوري الشمالي كيم جمجون يتجول
كعاشق ولهان في حدائق بوتين النوويه ويلقي
نظره اخيره على القاذفات الروسيه وصواريخ
كينج الفرد صوتيه معلنا عن عقد قرانه مع
مجموعه اسلحه روسيه استراتيجيه جديده جعلت
الامريكان يضعون ايديهم على صدورهم
منتظرين اندلاع حفله الزفاف ونقصد الحرب
العالميه المنتظره لتاتي النصيحه للا من
الغرب لانه لا ينبغي على اوكرانيا توقع
انضمامها الى حلف شمال الاطلسي حتى بعد
انتهاء الاعمال القتاليه على اراضيها وذلك
بحسب ما اكد موقع جيوب الذي قال ان ذلك من
اجل تفادي حدوث ازمه ثقه داخل النيتو في
الوقت الذي هاجم فيه الرئيس الروسي بوتين
سياسات الولايات المتحده قائلا واشنطن لا
تعرف تحقيق اهدافها الا بفرض العقوبات
الاقتصاديه او بالتهديدات العسكريه ولكنها
هي الازمه تحدث حقا في الطرف الاوكراني
حيث توعد الرئيس الاوكراني
بتوجيه رد حضاري على الدول التي حضرت
استيراد الحبوب وسلع الاوكرانيه رغم قرار
المفوضيه الاوروبيه برفع الحظر عنها وكانت
بولندا وسلوفاكيا وانغاريا قد اعلنت عن
فرض قيود على واردات الحبوب الاوكرانيه
فلماذا يدعم الاوروبيون اوكرانيا من جهه
ويحاربونها من اخرى فيما يدعم الروس
انفسهم بانفسهم حيث اعلن وزير الدفاع
الروسي سركيشي ان روسيا تطور الغواصات
النوويه جديده ومسيره تحت الماء مضيفا ان
البحريه الروسيه استقبلت السفيرتين هذا
العام وستتلقى اثنتي عشره اخرى بحلول
نهايه العام فالى اين ستذهب وحوش البحار
الروسيه هذه هل نحن امام حفله بحريه في
خضم الحرب الاوكرانيه ميدانيا وجه الجيش
الروسي احدى عشره ضربه باسلحه
عشره سفينه مسيره اوكرانيه وقوارب مع فرق
انزال في البحر واعلنت الدفاع الروسي ان
الضربات التي تم تنفيذها بين التاسع
والسادس عشر من سبتمبر الجاري اسفرت عن
تدمير مستودعات اسلحه غربيه ومرافق
الموانئ المستخدمه لنقل الاسلحه ونقاط
تمركز الجيش الاوكراني وها هو المصدر
يتحدث كالعاده
بينما كان الجيش الاوكراني قد اعلن ان
قواته قصفه انظمه دفاعا في غرب شبه جزيره
القرن في هجوم طويل المدى ليخرج جازل
المسكي ويعبر عن فرحته مشيدا بهذه العمليه
اما بوتين فعاد وقال ان 300 الف متعقد
وقعوا عقود للمشاركه بالعمليه العسكريه
مضيفا لسنا بحاجه لاستقطاب متطوعين من
الخارج اها شكلها هتولع يا جدعان والكلام
ده مش من عندنا احنا جبناه من القناه
الرسميه للحكومه الروسيه لتدور بين
الاحداث وتذكرنا هذه المره بالجنرال يوم
القيامه ارمج الدول فانه الجنرال الروسي
سروفيكن والذي اختفى عن الانظار في اعقاب
محاوله التمرد التي قامت بها مجموعه فاجنر
وفقا لوكاله فرانسبريس فقد دار سروفيكن في
المسجد الكبير في مدينه وهران الساحليه
الجزائريه ويظهر في الصور بجانب ضباط روز
يرتدون الزي العسكري بالاضافه الى امام
المسجد ابو عبد الله زيبار يا الهي هل
اعلن من كان يلقب بجزار بوتين توبه
وبالعوده الى الحرب الاوكرانيه فقد اعلن
رئيس بعثه اللجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر
في موسكو بوريس ميشيل استعداد الصليب
الاحمر للوساطه بين روسيا واوكرانيا في
تبادل الاسرى اذا طلب الطرف لذلك ومن جانب
اخر صحيفه
ان روسيا حركت ناقلات النفط غير المعززه
عبر طريق بحر الشمال الجليدي للمره الاولى
مما اثار مخاوف بشان وقوع تسرب كارثي في
القطب الشمالي وفي اغسطس الماضي حصلت
ناقلتان على الاذن بالقيام برحله بطول
3500 ميل على طول الساحل الشمالي لروسيا
على الرغم من انهما لا يطلق عليهما اسم
ناقلات الطبقه الجليديه
لتحمل الظروف الجليديه اي النابوتين يخطط
لامر غامض بتحريكه لهذه السفن فما هو
برايكم وبعيدا عن روسيا قال الرئيس التركي
رجب طيب اردوغان ان السويد لم تفي بعد
بوعودها لتركيا للموافقه على انضمامها الى
حلف النيتو يبدو ان حفيظ عثمان سيتراجع عن
توقيعه على انضمام السويد النيتو وليس ذلك
فحسب بل ان اردوغان قال ان بلاده تفكر في
انهاء مساعيها للانضمام الى الاتحاد
الاوروبي
الاحداث والتطورات في ليبيا الكارثه لم
تنتهي بانتهاء الاعصار حيث كان الهلال
الاحمر الليبي قد اعلن ان عدد ضحايا
العاصفه تجاوز
1100 وفاه بينما لا يزال احد عشر الفا
اخرون في عداد المفقودين كان رئيس هيئه
البحث والتعرف على المفقودين في ليبيا قد
اعلن انتشال 450 جثه من البحر خلال يومين
مشيرا الى انها كانت على مسافه 120 مترا
عن الشاطئ عن اي عدد كبير من الضحايا
نتحدث ليضيف رئيس الهيئه انه تم حتى الان
انتشار الجثث ثلاثه
الافثمانيه
وانه تم التعرف على هوياتهم بحسب الصحه
العالميه في احدث علامه على الاضطراب بين
اعضاء النخبه في المؤسسه العسكريه وسياسه
الخارجيه في بكين ذكر مسؤولون امريكيون
لصحيفه فاشل تانزل البريطانيه ان وزير
الدفاع الصيني لشنكوه وضع قيد التحقيق
جانبها الولايات المتحده خلصت الى ان الذي
لم يظهر علنا لاكثر من اسبوعين ترى
تجريدهم المسؤوليته كوزير للدفاع وتاتي
هذه الخطوه بعد شهرين من قيم الرئيس
الصيني
[موسيقى]